-Thank you so much.
Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you, thank you.
-I got to talk to you.
"Hawkeye" comes out tomorrow.
-I can't believe it.
-This is real deal.
You're part of the MCU.
-I mean, it's so cool
to hear it out loud.
It's crazy.
[ Cheers ]
-Do you remember where you were
when you found out?
-Oh, my God, yeah, but even
before then, I had a meeting
with Kevin Feige, Trinh Tran,
Jeremy Renner.
And I was -- you know, I went
onto the lot and I didn't have
the job yet, but I might
have felt like I did.
I went, like, behind
all these secret gates
and underground parking
and up crazy back elevators.
Oh, I mean, it was,
like, full lockdown mode.
I was like, "This is crazy."
But it was wild.
-So the Marvel offices are
like a Marvel movie?
-Yes, and the whole meeting was
whispered.
-Yeah, you had to,
like, jump over a thing
and swing from something.
-Exactly, yeah.
-No way, and you felt it.
You felt that you had it.
You're like "Okay, they want me
for this"?
-Well, I mean, you guys, this
is, like, this top secret.
There's got to be something
they know that I don't.
-I mean, you were -- Kevin's --
you were his first choice.
We actually have a video of him
saying this.
-Oh, my God.
-If you want to see this.
I wanted to surprise you
tonight.
-We had an ideal casting,
which was Hailee Steinfeld.
Like, wouldn't it be great
if her or somebody like her --
"Well, let's see if she'd be
interested in our world.
We don't know,"
and thankfully, she was.
-Isn't that pretty cool?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
-He wanted you.
You knew it. You felt it.
-Crazy.
I mean, I'm just so honored
to be a part of something
so incredible and to have
somebody like Kevin Feige
and the whole Marvel team and
everyone involved believe in me
enough to take on this
incredible role of
Kate Bishop is an honor.
-Not only does "Hawkeye"
premiere tomorrow,
but the final season of
your show "Dickinson"
is also airing now.
-Yes.
-What's it been like -- You're
fantastic in that as well.
You've been on our show,
thank you for coming on.
That's ending
as this is beginning.
-Is it odd because you have to
do two sets of interviews?
-It is bizarre.
It's definitely bittersweet.
You know, the last four years of
my life have been "Dickinson,"
which I feel so grateful for
because I feel like,
although the series might be
coming to an end,
I don't feel like
it's fully goodbye.
This character will definitely
stay with me.
Emily Dickinson's work will
always be a part of my life,
and I'm so grateful for that.
-That's awesome, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're great in it.
There are some rumors
swirling around,
as there always is around Marvel
stuff and Marvel projects,
and I was just wondering maybe
if you knew anything about this,
because "Hawkeye" is
set in New York City.
-Uh-huh. I can already tell you
I don't know. Go on.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I know, but you kind of
might know.
-I might. You're right, okay.
-Well, just saying, Spider-Man
is from New York.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, maybe, it would be
kind of cool if Spider-Man
maybe showed up.
-It would be very cool.
-It would be cool, right?
-It would be so cool.
-Yeah, you would freak out.
-I would absolutely freak out.
-Would your character freak out?
-More than likely.
-Yeah.
-Seems accurate for her.
-Yeah, but I guess
we'll never know.
-I guess we won't, really.
[ Laughter ]
-But also you were in
the animated Spider-Man?
-Yes, "Into the Spider-Verse."
-"Into the Spider-Verse."
-Yes.
-Which was amazing.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Gwen Stacy.
-Thank you.
-I don't know -- Can an animated
character show up in "Hawkeye"?
[ Laughter ]
-Anything is possible,
really, right?
I don't know the answer.
But it would be quite cool.
I don't know
how that would happen.
-Maybe they're watching
a television show.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, like, she's on the TV?
Or they're together watching?
We don't know.
-Yeah, I know, but you kind of
got excited about that,
which means that
you might know something.
-No, I genuinely don't know
anything, but I love the idea.
-I'm trying to get you
in trouble.
-We could pitch it.
-We could?
Kevin?
-Kevin?
-Kevin, you never ask me.
I'm never your first choice for
anything.
[ Laughter ]
But we had Jeremy on the show
yesterday,
and gosh, he's a nice guy.
But he's a great singer.
-He is.
-And I know you are
a fantastic singer.
-Oh, thank you.
-I'm a big fan.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did you guys sing on set
at all?
-Well, so, we shot
in New York City
around this time last year,
so Christmastime,
and our show takes place
during the holidays.
So it was very hard to hold back
the Christmas jingles
in between takes.
Until we were, like,
shooting in March
and we were still doing it,
then it got a little weird.
But no, we were
definitely singing.
-Did he give you any good advice
about being in
the Marvel Universe?
-You know, it was really just
having him there,
having an Avenger by my side
through this whole experience,
because, I don't know, I mean --
First of all, he's been doing
this for 10-plus years...
-10 years, yeah, absolutely.
-...which is so crazy.
And although I've been doing
this for some time,
I don't know that anything
really could have prepared me
for this kind of thing,
and Jeremy knew that.
So he just made himself so
available and he was so lovely,
and to have him
and his guidance.
-It's a giant thing,
and they have amazing fans.
loyal, loyal, loyal, loyal fans.
-It's incredible.
-Can you explain who you play
and what "Hawkeye" is about?
-Of course, so, I play
Kate Bishop from New York City.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She is an incredible, badass,
very confident young woman
who is a highly skilled archer
and fencer and swordswoman
and martial artist
and the list goes on.
And she's faced with her hero,
her lifelong idol in Hawkeye,
and then they find themselves
on the run, trying to unravel
this criminal conspiracy,
and yeah, it's the holiday time.
There's laughs and good humor
and a lot of depth
and a lot of layers in this very
character and grounded story.
-I can't wait to watch.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Hailee Steinfeld
and Jeremy Renner in "Hawkeye."
Take a look at this.
-Mommy, Mommy, a superhero!
-Wow, Stevie, you wanna say hi?
-Come on, kid.
-Puny tourist.
-Hey look, that one's you.
-No, it's Katniss Everdeen.
Let's go.
-Your problem is branding.
-No, my problem is you.
And this ninja suit and that
people are trying to kill you
because of this ninja suit.
The whole thing's a problem that
I'm going to solve today
so I can go home to my family.
-No, it's branding.
-Hailee Steinfeld, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Hawkeye" premieres tomorrow
on Disney+.